Russia is the President Vladimir Putin
has addressed the nation after Wagner
mercenary forces claimed control of
military sites in roster Von Don he
described the move as treason and said
decisive action will be taken
we will defend our country we will
defend our nation we will defend our
citizens against the threats we face
today some people are trying to use
their interests against our country we
need to make sure that we are fighting
in Ukraine for the sake of our country
and be sure the Traders must not be
there a lot of people have sacrificed
their lives for Russia and those that
are trying to sow rebellion and create
chaos will fail ultimately
accuses Russia's military leaders of
ordering airstrikes which killed
thousands of his men he's vowing to seek
what he calls Justice for the dead
Michael Apple has the latest
this video appears to show Wagner forces
and their leader yevgeni pragosan
entering military headquarters in rostov
ich
in a subsequent video he is seated
between senior commanders one of whom
had earlier broadcaster video urging
precaution to reconsider his Rebellion
order
the mercenary boss says his men control
important sites in the city
[Applause]
we are in the headquarters it's 7 30 a.m
military installations including the
Airfield in rostov are under our control
the aircraft go on schedule there are no
problems we took control to prevent Air
Force strikes against us so the Air
Force can continue attacks on the
ukrainians
tension between Wagner and the kremlin's
Armed Forces escalated during the Battle
of bakmud where the mercenaries played a
crucial role in the drawn out fight to
capture the city
but progossian accuses the Russian army
commanders of withholding ammunition and
other supplies from his men Finland
more recently Russia ordered Wagner
mercenaries to sign contracts with the
Russian defense Ministry by the end of
June Russia's military leadership is
accusing progression of carrying out an
armed Mutiny
you must do this before it's too late
obey the will and command of the elected
president of the Russian Federation stop
the convoys return to bases and places
where you're stationed
Security in Moscow has been tightened
military vehicles can be seen guarding
government buildings in Russia's capital
Prague says He commands 25 000 men with
more reported to be joining Wagner's
ranks as they made their way into rostov
while in Saint Petersburg Police raided
Wagner's headquarters Michael Apple Al
Jazeera
well we have four correspondents
following this developing story Jonah
Hall will give us reaction from Kiev
we'll also speak to him about the
Russian airstrikes there Ali Hashem is
in Russian controlled Donetsk sonaga
Yago is following developments from
London but first two Euro shop of Oliver
in Moscow
Julia what do you make of what we've
heard from a Russian President Vladimir
Putin
well indeed he spoke a while ago and now
we're getting some official reactions to
his speech we know that foreign Ministry
spokeswoman spoke about Unity within the
country uh while it seems like there is
a new form of expression of loyalty to
Vladimir Putin and the Russian Armed
Forces officials on that social networks
rise the name of the region or their
organization with words we are with the
president so in his speech to the nation
Mr Putin has said that Russia is
fighting for its future and its identity
the authorities in Russia will not allow
the country to be divided and they will
of course protect its people he called
the situation in the country internal
betrayal saying that any internal unrest
is is a deadly threat to the to the
nation and to the state and he also
mentioned the conflict with Ukraine
saying that the entire Western military
machine was directed against Russia
according to him Wagner's fighters who
participated in the special military
operation in Ukraine are heroes and now
they shouldn't join the military
Rebellion which is taking place right
now in the country also some telegram
channels associated with the Wagner
group claimed that there were some
clashes with the ministry of Defense in
the veronis region and Military
correspondents write about the work of
Aviation along the M4 highway there but
we can't independently verify those
reports while the ministry of Defense
itself issued an official statement
addressing fighters of the Wagner group
saying that they had got involved in
precursions criminal activities and
participated in an armed in the armed
Rebellion so they also guaranteed all
fighters safety
if they surrendered and we also see that
according to some media reports uh uh
some Fighters indeed returned to their
initial positions as they had been asked
by the Army uh however according to
various sources since the first
publications of preggersian statements
and his actions they haven't been
confirmations of like big clashes
between Wagner and the regular army
forces and there are also reports that
the Wagner group Now controls the
command center and a number of security
and Military facilities in Russia's
southern region of rostov including an
Airfield but according to reports
military planes that continue carrying
out their missions so also there were
reports about the situation in veronis
but we can't verify those reports either
that Wagner have captured facilities in
veronage so there were some pictures and
with preggers negotiating with some
high-ranking Army generals and we we we
heard that they were warning progression
about consequences of his actions anula
we understand that security has been
stepped up in the capital there
well yes absolutely uh indeed it has I
mean security has been uh tightened all
over Russia in Moscow anti-terrorist
measures have been taken and the police
controlled the roads in and around
Moscow several fighter jets were spotted
in the resign region a huge traffic jam
it is now reported on the M4 Don Highway
in the rostov and veronis regions
hundreds of people have been stuck there
since Friday evening and there are also
reports about armored vehicles on the
roads of all those regions as well so we
understand that what is going on here
right now is the tensions and the
situation is really heating up so we we
do continue monitoring the situation
here
well yeah thank you well joining us now
from Donetsk is Ali Hashem Ali what's
happening in rostov online as far as
you're aware
well since this morning the statements
from the Wagner group about taking
control of the Central Command in rustov
and later on President Putin himself
acknowledging that there is a problem in
rostov and that governing headquarters
are blocked and there is a need for
solving this problem as he said now why
rustov since yesterday when Wagner's
first statement came out Wagner's
Commander
Evgeni prugojin claimed that the defense
minister planned the attack on his the
the attack on his forces from rustov and
that he's going to march with his forces
to the stove to take revenge and that's
what happened at least with respect to
the Wagner group being in the city now
there are no reports as Julia said about
resistance or clashes or any kind of
military confrontations in in rostov
however a an Affiliated telegram Channel
with PMC Wagner posted a picture of a
helicopter a Russian helicopter that
they claim to have downed uh close to
the veronese area and this could be the
first of its uh kind of uh confrontation
or an engagement between the Wagner
group and the Russian military just in
case this is confirmed now on the other
side all roads surrounding rustov are
blocked towards krasnadar towards
Donetsk towards varunaj and this is
these are measures that were taken by
the local authorities in uh in parallel
with these developments and Ali how
could these developments shape the
situation on the battlefield itself
well Kerry over here for example in
Donetsk we've been hearing since
yesterday a lot of bombing a lot of
artillery coming in around the city
this could be related and at the same
time the ministry of Defense yesterday
spoke about a new Ukrainian
counter-offensive in the city of bakmut
building on what's Happening inside
Russia so these are two main
developments that we can talk about now
how this is going to impact the whole
front line it's also going to be
important to understand who is really in
control we don't know who is who is in
control right now now Wagner Chief says
he is in the command in rostov and in
the central military command there
however who is in Direct Control this is
not something that we know for now this
is also not going to impact only uh
Russia's Frontline with Ukraine as we
know Wagner group has its uh mercenaries
in several countries around the world
and they used to be described as
Russia's arm in Africa in Syria in Libya
so this is also going to have a big
impact on Russia's footprint around the
world
okay for now Ali thank you well
meanwhile there's been no pause in
Russia's offensive in Ukraine Let's
cross live to Jonah Hall in Kiev so how
is this voluntary development being
viewed there
it almost goes without saying doesn't it
that you Ukraine's political and
Military leadership will be watching
extremely closely uh the way that these
events are unfolding politically we've
heard from mikhaila podoliak who's a
senior advisor to president zielinski
who points to what he described as
obvious splits in the Russian Elite and
he said events in Russia are just
beginning so they will have expectations
uh that this has some way to go yet
militarily of course
there will be questions about how this
could affect the overall course of the
war given how important roster roster
vondon is as a military command post
it's head for the headquarters of the
Southern military District in Russia it
is where command and control is being
exercised across much of the battlefield
in Ukraine and clearly they will be
wandering here the extent to which
command and control is potentially going
to be disrupted but I think more
specifically on the battlefield itself
in Ukraine they'll be looking for two
things distinctly the first will be the
extent to which and we can't answer this
independently the extent to which Wagner
mercenary forces have been redeployed
from areas of the battlefield where they
have been active in order to head to
rostov ondon and other places
potentially vacating defenses in places
like bakmut in the east of the country
that they fought so hard to win control
over and therefore allowing Ukraine to
redouble its efforts there it is one of
the pressure points of its
counter-offensive and the other thing
they'll be looking for is the way in
which Russian forces traditional Russian
forces may also be redeployed in order
to confront Wagner forces inside Russia
Russia is heavily heavily extended
inside Ukraine some might say
overextended and if there are defenses
to be mounted in the country itself they
may have to find those on the front line
and Ukraine has been mounting probing
attacks for weeks now in the early
stages if it's counter-offensive it will
have gained a pretty good idea of the
way Russia's defenses are laid out and
it will be watching closely to see
whether any new spaces are opened up for
them to probe further
Angela despite all of this overnight
strikes have continued at where you are
even
yeah I'm sure you can see behind me I'm
in a a pretty Rubble strewn parking lot
of a high-rise apartment building here
in Kiev that was struck in the early
hours of this morning a reminder of
course if one were needed that the war
very much goes on uh pieces debris of
some 20 cruise missiles that were fired
at the Capitol brought down by air
defenses in what was a very noisy and
active defense night here in the capital
uh nevertheless struck this building
scithing huge holes out of three sides
of it igniting a fire on three floors
three people are known to have died
emergency service workers believe there
could be more people under the rubble
and as we speak people going through
belongings that are strewn across the
roadway here looking at the wreck and
Rubble of cars I can see uh items
personal items that have been blown out
of apartment buildings there's a pillow
beside me here and what looks like some
children's uh some children's pajamas
there would have been an air raid Alert
in place of course but frankly these air
raid alerts happen so often now in the
early hours of the morning that quite a
lot of people probably decide that they
are safer in their Apartments than
having to spend night after night in
underground bunkers okay that is the
situation in Kiev at the moment we're
going to continue with this and bring in
Sonia Gallego who's in London for us now
what's the reaction been from the
British capital
well there has been uh so far an
intelligence update that's just been
issued from the ministry of Defense
where they've stated that in the early
hours of uh of the 24th of June the
Saturday that the feud between
priguration and uh and the Russian mod
has escalated into outright military
confrontation uh they've spoken about in
this in this intelligence update about
how the Wagner group forces have crossed
from occupied Ukraine into Russia and in
rostov online how Wagner has almost
certainly occupied uh key security sites
and also how over the coming hours it
states in this in this intelligence
update the Loyalty of Russia's security
forces and especially the Russian
national guard will be key to how the
crisis plays out this represents the
most significant challenge to the
Russian state in recent times that's the
British Ministry of Defense giving its
own intelligence update to the ongoing
situation there but so far there hasn't
been any outright governmental reaction
from this I think the tendency is for
there to be more of a very very let's
watch and wait to see exactly what is
happening here with the military
intelligence keeping those abreast of
the situation as to how this is going to
be playing out but it's going to be
interesting to note going forward
depending on how it plays out how this
is going to affect uh not just how the
British government responds to it as
well but also in the European Union
as uh let's not forget also that Wagner
forces are all over the world as well in
Venezuela in Syria and right across
Africa you have some 30 33 000 troops
stationed there as well this is going to
be a very interesting point especially
for France who has seen countries in
across Africa who'd previously had ties
with the French defense system there to
turn away from that and focus uh their
uh their uh ties to to the Wagner uh
group it's going to be also a very
interesting opportunity for France to be
able to say look what's happening what's
playing out there France can really be
only your stable defense partner here so
it'll be interesting to see how that is
going to be going forward in terms of
how the situation on the ground in
Russia and Ukraine is going to be
playing out with the rest of the
European Union
Sonia Gallego thank you for that well
with this fast moving situation the
Charles Stratford joins us now he's on
the road to buckmut in eastern Ukraine
Charles what can you tell us
yes you're right we are on the road to
Eastern we've seen a lot of troop
movements this morning
behind us there's a lot of shelling that
we're hearing as well we've seen troop
carrying helicopters in the area of
course bakmut was pretty much the
epicenter for Wagner's big push it was
where we saw pregosian make those
repeated criticisms of the Russian
defense Ministry criticizing them for
not supplying enough arms and it was the
place really that Wagner was was so
instrumental in taking control of that
City so we've been speaking to Ukrainian
soldiers in this area for their kind of
reaction
um basically morale amongst Ukrainian
soldiers seems to have risen they were
very buoyed the men that we spoke to one
man saying that they were now ready to
exploit what he described as the chaos
in Russia and push even harder he said
that in the last couple of weeks since
this counter-offensive has started
certainly around bakmut the situation
there the progress made by Ukrainian
forces in that counter-offensive has
been slow flanking attacks from the
south
um both the East and and and the West
um he now said that they are going to
push even harder so it's going to be
very interesting in the next 48 hours or
so and that's something that an
ambulance man told us um there's a lot
of ambulances positioned as you can
imagine along this road ready to take
you Ukrainian troops out
um and he said yeah we're going to
basically sit for 48 hours but not to
put too fine a point on it we're very
happy with the situation in Russia at
the moment and this kind of chaos is
going to be exploited we can imagine by
Ukrainian forces probing for weaknesses
in Russia's defensive lines in the hours
and days ahead
Charles trout but uh thanks very much
for that update